Leo Carlson sends it off brought ahead now by
Carlson down the wing Carlson with a reach shot
it's GL by gorv and he's going in Carlson's
all over and makes the steel Leo Carlson a
centering pass but it's broken up by McKinnon
that could have gotten ugly in a hurry but the
ABS counter attack McKinnon FS mcder with a
shot he scores Curtis mcder the Chrysler Town
and Country just racking up the goals back
into the lineup tonight and giving the ABS
a one- nothing lead another one McKinnon just
skated by the bench with the biggest smile on
his face I've seen all season long Curtis MCG
just his six game of the season back into the
lineup since his game-winning goal against the
Minnesota Wild what a sweep pass by McKinnon and
McAn the sniper his goals per minute the
last two games are best on the plan fou
brings it up the near side as will take it
away good play by Dr man him with a wrist
shot Sav by Gibson that puck right up in the
air MOA had a great Le here Manson by Design
shot that on the ice on the far right pad not
looking to score hoping for a deflection or a
rebound back to the avalan Zone there's Manson
turning and chasing ABS have made a change fired
up for Taves he'll bump it in John Gibson gave
up three on Saturday night in Period one two
to Bowen byon and one to Devon and then shut
it down save by gorv ripped off the inboards
and tar got chased off that puck Sam Jones
throws it behind the asge cage and now Byron
takes it from his goaling here's mcder got
it through leushin and out it goes a foot
race toar trying to get there into the duck Zone
nice job by Tomas tar absolutely turning on the
Jets into the far Corner lausin pounded it quick
shot there blocker save taken by Carrick centering
pass oh and it's fanned upon Ducks get it back
long shot save rebound save by gor that was
brilliant keep going mcder absolutely in the
high slot it's given up good us with a shot
saved by gorg he had to fight that off his upper
body it's just cool as it looks let me tell you
turnover by The Avalanches Troy Terry is back
in shoot strong side save Again by dioris he
is a joystick player just named to Canada's uh
World Junior team today as well Tak it by the
Ducks wrap around try knocked away a quick shot
off the side of the net and the Ducks right now
are absolutely swarming in the avalan zone that
was a good job by Oscar olison just in the lineup
with the puck now got to stick in the lane to
stop that shot from going against georia here's
Alon back on his skates he'll find malinsky Long
R shot easy save resets gr back up top for T now
McKinnon bumps it turn around shot gloved slides
up fortain one timer never got through back to
McKinnon cross eyes ranted it looks dancing
holding shooting oh my goodness Gibson got a
piece Mo I'm looking exactly on Miko's back here
and as he pulls back Gibson has that corner option
available see how the glove is low so it's right
there it's for him and then as soon as Mo releases
that puck Gibson's fast enough to get his glove
up there but because Moo's going backward shoots
over the top of the net Far Side DS play Carson
shoots s goria trying to find a hole get through
but here's the rookie Leo Carlson comes in see the
flex on that stick that's a tremendous release and
it happened quick as they come in the zone watch
him to the stick over and off and the Collision
Frankie V sweeps it across mov is in with the
shot off the post loose puck in the crease Dior
up with a snow angel and there is a whistle and
then mitov bangs it off the honor the ABS hanging
on to a one- nothing lead steered ahead by Caleb
Jones this is olon with a shot save rebound save
Gibson rebound kick to the near side Taves floats
one deep and that's wide to the net glove down by
manson still kept in Long wrist jots head gets
it jump St Nathan Ken rips it home into a wide
open go mou perfect feat from drwan the ABS have
two nothing lead for Nathan McKinnon is ninth of
the season in coming Mo this was all because the
ABS battled to keep Pucks in the zone miles W was
over here on the blue line barely kept it in Josh
Manson on the far side barely kept it in and after
getting Puck after Puck towards the net finally
they got a nice play on a rebound a little pass
over to Nathan McKinnon from Jonathan Drew in and
B AB up two toight people have been talking about
McKinnon's goal scoring fired off for Daves walks
his way down the wing Dave up top Jack Johnson
with a long wrer Sav by Gibson slow my goodness
how that stay out so the pucks on net obviously
and then oh there it is oh what a save that was
that's why Jen was up in arms behind the net so
it comes down from the Moon Jan finds It Wide
Open net and he heals the puck a little bit but
Gibson's able to get his foot out there combined
with drewan catching that a bit on the heel right
there back it comes to the near side Dr finds
McKinnon out of the Trap ISO a back hand shot
the a with it Logan o car kept banging away and
banging away I think Gibson thought he had a
pin but he did not boys grab Knuckles beside the
pitch but it alls about number 29 and the simple
play just going to the net and throwing it on the
pads and seeing you can get a little bit lucky
and Logan oconor as you said just squeezes out the
backside and scores his easiest career goal but he
doesn't get there without hard work battling in
front you can see he's got the young defenseman
Leno on him stepping into zon immediately picked
up by fer given off for Mo trying to get through
shiot Sav by Gibson it'll get on top of that puck
will take a timeout 122 to going in the third I
love that and back here after that hit by good is
McMan went by the entire Ducks bench said be ready
it's coming and then Carrick responded back to
say say big ma uh-oh steal by Carrick walking in
Carrick down the slot shoots scores short-handed
goal gorgi have got a lot of it but it bounces
over his left pad it's a 3-1 game well that's
not the guy I was expecting to store cuz Carrick
told he wasn't saying anything about scoring a
short-handed goal just picks Miko's pocket right
here twice and Garrick not known to be the goal
scoring machine gets that right off the tip of the
glove GV almost has it in his 12th Pro season
only 187 NHL games spent a lot of time in the
American Hockey League but he finds some magic on
that shorty Sam Carrick markam in their thre man
triangle fed off calorin Carlson looking back to
CL in front save by gorgia a couple of saves Puck
is loose and that one's underneath his right pass
going to ruin him into the end boards he didn't
get back to the front of the net as fast as he
wanted right there Devon keeping the feet in range
serving cross ice pass shot off the side of it
by Carlson little bit late on the release Fowler
to The Far Side Terry sends it across Carlson
shoots and scores wide open net great scam pass
Leo Carlson burns the ABS again his eighth goal
of the year in this is 17th game it's a 3-2 game
with still a minute to go he gets that Puck he's
so dangerous to shoot top right hand side of your
screen instead of shooting hits that scene pass
and GV just didn't pick up on it fast enough see
how he's looking shot the whole way didn't even
have Carlson in his rearview mirror let alone
side mirror and makes just a sneak pass across and
car duck have it Colton on the four check takes it
away trying to wait for the ab get more players on
in front loose Puck creas Gibson reaches couldn't
get to it Leno's on his move into the Zone gives
it off Terry tried to give it off sa by gor loose
Puck at the side of the net on their toes watching
this and you can see just trying to get that
backhand in Ryan stro he's having an outstanding
year with 17 points his career best to this
point and that will do it here at ball Arena oh my
goodness the ABS hang on through injury misfortune